David is an Oregon hi David how are you
hey I'm doing good how are you better
than I deserve what's up hey how you
doing man so I'm out doing the debt
snowball and I've been doing it for the
last several years and I'm getting
toward the end of it I got about seven
thousand dollars in student loans left
and five thousand dollars on a car
student loans would be my next thing to
tackle
yet at the beginning of last year I had
my stepfather pass away and we had a lot
of liquidate a lot of his toys boats
cabin things like this and these are all
things that he's earned and you know has
been you know him and my mother and uh
you know keeping for themselves and
whatnot but she's now gifting me $20,000
and I'm nervous on how to approach this
situation for what she's got right now
she's got it in an IRA and what she says
it's going to be making about five
hundred dollars a year it doesn't seem
like the best option for it I'm just
wondering what what would you suggest I
do with this money how old is she oh
she's 71 okay well she can cash out her
IRA if she wants and pay taxes on it
at 71 there'll be no penalties and she
can gift you up to $15,000 a year
without any gift tax any more than that
and there would be a gift tax on it
unless she does some more sophisticated
financial planning which would be called
the uniform estate tax credit and the
unified estate tax credit and so you so
she's prompt but after she pays your
taxes she's probably not gonna have
20,000 probably gonna be more like 15 if
she's cashing out an IRA she got played
am I to live on yeah yes he's doing it
he he had a pension through FedEx and
she's got his Social Security and his
pension she's got about I want to say
3,000 coming in a month that she's
living on and yeah I'm a money other
than this money uh not that I'm aware of
at the moment I mean she does not need
to give
there's a money then she's broke I'm not
sure you know the house is paid for and
she's got you know this money coming in
monthly yeah I'm not exactly sure what
her listen if she has $3,000 a month
coming in and she's 70 years old and as
a paid for house and all she has to her
name is $20,000 IRA she just nothing to
give that away she's got no money man
she's got it she's got a 401 K I think
she's got about 80,000 and there as well
yeah it's not enough you know she had
800,000 I wants to give you 20 that's
fine but she got she got a grand or her
whole name man she don't she don't be
giving this money away so sweet of her
but she doesn't need to do that I would
tell her to hold on to that right now
and you keep working your death snowball
that would be my advice hey thank you
for the call